all right let's get to the draft the
best dual sport athletes football and
baseball edition i'll give you the first
pick as an early birthday gift
thank you very much it's very early i'll
just give you that clue uh bo jackson
bo jackson has got to be the first pick
right i mean he's the only person who's
ever been an all-star in both baseball
and in football pro bowl or that's what
we decided to call it over here uh in
the nfl so he's great right and the
funny thing is
that i think people probably my age or
younger probably don't quite know how
good beau jackson is but i have a very
good mother who did a good job of
raising me so i know just how good beau
jackson was and the funny thing too is i
don't remember know if you remember this
mike a few years ago adam laroche's kid
at uh spring training for the white sox
was basically going up to bo jackson
asking who are you and what are you what
do you do like why are you here and bo
jackson had to be like uh kid
let me tell you a little bit of
something about me so people more people
should know who bo jackson is who i
think are my age and younger because he
is one of the best two sport athletes
ever
beau jackson was a phenomenon the beau
knows beau book the bow knows
commercials for nike they're still
available on youtube they're hilarious
his performance in i think it was the 89
all-star game was it 89 the year that
he had 89 89 all-star game and just some
of the things he did over the course of
his baseball career were uncanny
breaking the bat over his knee breaking
the bat over his helmet i remember a
time where he caught a foul ball in the
stands and a guy tried to tag up from
third base and he threw him out after he
pulled himself out of the stands i mean
just amazing what the guy could do and
it's a shame you know
we we accept the fact that football
players are going to be injured
when his career ended because of that
freak hip injury in a playoff game
against the bengals i i remember that
was like that hurt you understand guys
are gonna get hurt and there's always
gonna be somebody else and you do get
desensitized to it that one hurt because
of what might have been from bo jackson
deion sanders for me even though he
wasn't a great baseball player he was
able to play at the major league level
played in the world series game i was at
the game miles october 10 1992 when he
came from atlanta to pittsburgh
and played in the sunday night game for
the braves against the pirates in the
nlcs that year
i had just turned one there's another
clue for you uh dion sanders obviously
uh
obviously i think when we're talking
about guys who have been good in both
sports or even just played both sports
he's one of the best to probably ever do
it because even if he's just you know an
average major league baseball player he
didn't lead the league in triples one
year with 14 which is ridiculous because
he did it i think in 97 games that's not
something that you should be able to do
and i think it just shows off his speed
and athleticism so he was awesome next
guy would have to go with brian jordan
because even though he wasn't playing in
both leagues at the same time he was
still able to do it he goes from being a
safety um in the nfl player for the
falcons and then he goes to major league
baseball and has a long career goes from
1992 out of 2006 i believe so look at
somebody we were talking about a hell of
an athlete he's a hell of an athlete you
can't just i think uh downplay anybody
that can be a professional and start
games and be as good as he was in both
leagues like that all-star 1999.
yeah
awesome choice that's a name that's not
remembered much because it was in that
dion sanders era and it's like all of a
sudden brian jordan says see you later
football i'm going to play for the
cardinals and he had a nice baseball
career i'll go kyler murray even though
he hasn't played major league baseball
yet the fact that he was a top 10 pick
in the mlb draft which has like 283
rounds the fact that he was regarded and
still is so highly by baseball remember
it wasn't that long ago he's at the
phoenix suns game with the oakland a's
hat on and and and yeah i like the fact
that he is the rare nfl player
who has the ability to say if i don't
play football
i can still go play another professional
sport and make as much money and that's
going to be some interesting leverage
when the time comes for him to negotiate
his second contract and i also can't
help but wonder how much losing he will
tolerate before he says maybe i'll go
try something else and he's got the
skill to do it and you can't help but
wonder whether with that level of skill
he doesn't want to go do it at some
point is it pulling him away from
football a couple of others real quickly
before we take a break john elway
obviously was a great baseball player
jeff semarcha would have been a
first-round pick at receiver coming out
of notre dame he had a very good career
made more money than calvin johnson
frankly and would have been drafted in
about the same era a couple years after
that and also i got to mention this guy
because he was taken in the 17th and
final round of the 1973 draft by the
minnesota vikings the same draft that
brought them chuck foreman in round one
i had that awesome chuck foreman hoodie
on yesterday round 17. do you know who
it was the baseball player who was taken
by the vikings at your miles do you know
do you know
i have no idea uh you stumped me dave
winfield dave winfield he was drafted
football baseball basketball and he
never played football and the vikings
drafted him in round 17.
you